Why is RSA secure?
The security of RSA is based
on the hypothesis that
factoring a very large number is very,
very hard.
When we say a very large number, we
mean a integer that is at least 512 bit,
but often in the range of
1024 bits to 4096 bits.
That is, even such a large integer
is going to take a long time
to factor it into two primes.
On the other hand,
if someone finds a very efficient way
to factor a large number into primes,
then the security of RSA can be broken.
Here's why.
The public key is given, so
we know n and we know e.
If we can efficiently factor n into
p x q, where p and q are two primes,
then we can computer
totient(n) as (p- 1)(q- 1).
And if we can compute totient(n)
knowing the public key e,
we can then find its multiplicative
inverse, mod totient(n),
and this inverse is the public key d.
Therefore if we can efficiently factor
a large integer into two primes
that would mean that from the public
key we can derive the private key.
And that would break the security of RSA
because if you know the private key then
you can decrypt confidential messages or
you can also forge digital signatures.